do you think
this thing we got this this mind
is unique in the universe
in terms of how difficult it is to build
so
is it possible that we're the the most
beautiful thing that the universe has
constructed both the most beautiful the
most ugly but certainly the most complex
so look at evolutionary time uh the
dinosaurs ruled the earth for 135
million years
we've been around for a million years
so one versus 135. so
dinosaurs were extinct you know about 60
million years ago and mammals that had
been happily evolving
as tiny little creatures for 30 million
years then took over the planet
and then you know dramatically radiated
about 60 million years ago
out of these mammals came the neocortex
formation so basically the the neocortex
which is sort of the outer layer of our
brain
compared to our quote-unquote reptilian
brain which we share the structure of
with all of the dinosaurs they didn't
have that and yet they ruled the planet
so how many other planets have still you
know mindless dinosaurs
where strength was the only dimension uh
ruling the planet
so there was something weird that
annihilated the dinosaurs
and again you could look at biblical
things of sort of god coming and wiping
out his creatures and yes to make room
for the next ones
so um the mammals basically sort of took
off the planet and then grew
this cognitive capability of this
general-purpose machine
and primates push that
to extreme and humans among primates
have just
exploded that hardware but that hardware
is selected for
survival it's selected for procreation
it's initially selected with this very
simple darwinian view of the world
of random mutation ruthless selection
and then selection for making more of
yourself
if you look at human cognition
it's gone down a weird evolutionary path
in the sense that
we are expanding an enormous amount of
energy on this
apparatus between our ears that is
wasting what 15
of our bodily energy 20 like some
enormous
percentage of our calories
go to function our brain
no other species makes that big of a
commitment
that has basically taken energetic
changes for efficiency
on the metabolic side for humanity
to basically power that thing and our
brain is both
enormously more efficient than other
brands but also
despite this efficiency enormously more
energy consuming
so and if you look at just the sheer
folds
that the human brain has again our skull
could only
grow so much before it could no longer
go through the pelvic
opening and kill the mother
at every birth so but yet the fault
continued
effectively creating just so much more
capacity
the evolutionary uh context
in which this was made is enormously
fascinating
and it has to do with other humans
that we have now killed off or that have
gone extinct
and that has now created this weird
place of humans on the planet
as the only species that has this
enormous hardware
so that can basically make us think that
there's something very weird and unique
that happen in human evolution that
perhaps has not been recreated elsewhere
maybe the asteroid didn't hit
you know sister earth and the dinosaurs
are still ruling
and you know any any kind of proto-human
is squished and eaten for breakfast
basically
um however we're not as unique
as we like to think because there was
this enormous diversity of other
human-like forms and once you make it to
that stage where you have a
neocortex-like explosion of
wow we're now competing on intelligence
and we're now competing on social
structures and we're now competing on
larger and larger groups and being able
to
coordinate and being able to have
empathy
the concept of empathy the concept of an
ego
the concept of a self of self-awareness
comes probably from being able to
project another person's intentions
to understand what they mean when you
have these large
cognitive groups large social groups so
me being able to sort of create a mental
model of how you think
may have come before i was able to
create a personal mental model of how do
i think
so this introspection probably came
after
this sort of projection and this empathy
which basically means
you know passion pathos suffering
but basically sensing so basically
empathy means
feeling what you're feeling trying to
project your emotional state
onto my cognitive apparatus and i think
that
is what eventually led to
this enormous cognitive explosion that
happened in humanity
so you know life itself
in my view is uh inevitable on every
planet inevitable
inevitable but the evolution of life to
self-awareness and cognition and all the
incredible things that humans have done
you know that might not be as inevitable
you